it was reaction White House chief of
staff mark meadows you know the
president did help out did he not in
Washington DC the president did help out
in Minneapolis and in those two areas we
saw a dramatic change didn't we well we
saw a dramatic change Shaun in the
tragic news that you're sharing tonight
unfortunately is going to repeat itself
over and over again if we do not get
behind our law enforcement if we do not
make sure that we stand up for law nor
and this president is doing is exactly
that in fact he's the only thing that
stands between a mob and the American
people you know first it's the statutes
then it's the businesses then it's their
homes you know sadly we have a loss of
life and yet this president is willing
and not only willing but has already put
forth federal resources to make sure
that we can restore law and order he did
that about ten days ago not only in DC
but across the nation that's the untold
story where this president was willing
and and did indeed provide federal
resources in Minneapolis as you
mentioned also in Seattle Portland when
we look at some of these cities st.
Louis as he goes forward he's making
sure that we have not only the
Department of Justice but the Department
of Homeland Security and others to make
sure that our communities are safe it is
time that Joe Biden eventually condemns
all of these people that are saying that
we should defund the police it's not
enough to be against that policy he
needs to come out and say you have to go
the other way and support our law law
enforcement officers we're gonna go over
some of his by the way all the Democrats
modern Democrats praising the former
Klansmen Robert KKK burg Joe Biden's
comments on segregationist comments on
integration from the past the mob and
the media ignore this mark Meadows I
watched the president by the way very
highly rated on Friday night his speech
at Mount Rushmore and I watched his
speech on Saturday night the fourth of
July and he rice there's no perfect
country on the face of the earth my
friend Barry Farber recently passed away
great pioneer and talk radio there's no
country on the face of the earth that's
accumulated more power abused at less
than
this one and I had and used that power
for the advance of the human condition
america mark meadows we paid the price
we beat back the forces as the president
talked about in his speeches of fascism
Nazism Imperial Japan communism and now
more recently radical Islamism America
did that and made the world a better
safer place and that may be one of the
reasons so many people around the world
want to come into America and will
building walls to vet people well you're
exactly right Sean is was our founding
fathers imperfect men that truly founded
this nation or judeo-christian values
that said what we need to do is form a
more perfect union and indeed each and
every day has been an advancement of
that to make sure that not only are we
the the the best country on the face of
the globe but more importantly we
continue to stand up for those values
for those who can't speak for themselves
this president has been willing to do
that you mentioned the speech there at
Mount Rushmore not only was it a
historic speech but he laid out really
the difference are we going to be for
Anarchy or are we going to be for the
rule of law and making sure that
American citizens feel safe once again
in their home this president's willing
to do that where is Joe Biden in his
basement you know it's amazing we've
seen Joe Biden for 40 years talk a good
game 50 125 years combined failure him
Pelosi and Schumer well and as we look
at that it's it's not only that they're
just talking a good game but they fail
to act and when they fail to act there
are real consequences of that and and
sadly what we're seeing is each and
every day those consequences really are
played out on Main Street across America
and we've got to do something about it
and the time is now and this president
is committed to do that
he's elected his entire team to work on
that America will be unrecognizable if
it's Pelosi Schumer Biden and in it and
they implement this insane agenda
by the way I told you you weren't gonna
leave permanently I did twist your armor
a little bit on national TV we're glad
to have you or you are cheaper it's
great to be back thanks so much god
bless america